[Music]
pree suasion is the process of arranging
for an audience to agree with your
message before they encounter it now
that might sound like some form of magic
but it's not it's established science
very often we can use priests way civ
tactics even other kinds of influence
tactics on ourselves to increase the
likelihood that we will reach our goals
that we will obtain the outcomes that we
hope for in a particular situation
there's research for example to show
that if you depict four people an image
of a runner winning a race they become
more achievement-oriented and actually
achieve their goal to a greater extent
while that runner is in the background
there's another piece of research a
follow-up research that shows that if
you depict four people an image of
Rodin's the thinker you know that the
statue they become more analytic and
deliberative and they're more likely to
solve problems difficult complex
problems that they're faced with so this
is something we can do to ourselves if
we have a task that requires a lot of
energy and motivation put a picture of a
runner winning a race in the corner of
your computer screen where it you'll see
that queue there while you're performing
the task if you're analyzing a budget
perhaps or developing some plan that
requires a lot of strategic thinking put
a picture of the thinker there and
you're more likely to achieve that
particular goal the thing is we get to
control the queues in our environment
that send us in directions that are
likely to be successful for the
particular task we have at hand when
writing my book pre suasion I dedicated
it to my grandchildren
and there was something I did for myself
two priests weighed me to make that the
best possible book I could develop and
produce it was to put the following
image in my mind of each of my
grandchildren who are young right now
here's the image when they're old enough
to read it I've left a copy with their
parents for each of them and I want
their parents to give them the book and
say you see this this book was dedicated
to you well it better be a good book it
better be the highest quality book I can
arrange and so while I was writing that
book there was a quorum there was a
corner photograph of my grandkids on the
screen of my computer that picture kept
me focused on quality no short cuts
allowed this is for my grandkids it
better be the best book I can possibly
generate when I first started
investigating the influence process I
actually became a spy of sorts I went
undercover to all of the major
professions of our society dedicated to
getting us to say yes and I took
training I enrolled in the training
programs of salespeople fundraisers
recruiters public relations specialists
and so on to see what were the
techniques that were working most widely
across the range the broadest range of
these influence strategies these
influence approaches and what what I
found was interesting in that there was
a particular kind of practitioner within
those
fluence professions who rose to the top
almost invariably it wasn't the
individual who spent most of his or her
time crafting the message that they sent
although that was important to them it
was that they crafted what they said and
did immediately before they delivered
their message that was the
differentiator between the average
scores and the Aces of each profession
those people who were the highest
achievers were priests waiters they they
acted like expert gardeners they knew
that it didn't matter how good this
seemed that you had might be if you
didn't prepare the earth for it first it
wasn't going to bear fullest fruit so
they cultivated the earth they they they
pre treated the ground before they
planted their seed with their message
they did something that caused the
recipients of their message to have a
positive state of mind before they
encountered the message itself the
interesting question is how do you go
about cultivating the earth how do you
arrange for people to be in a frame of
mind that is conducive to the the
message that you want it to send it is
to recognize first of all what is the
central element of your message what is
the feature of your message that would
make it most wise for people to accept
your offer
right and then you take that dimension
and go to the moment before you deliver
your message and give people
people's attention to that idea to that
dimension let me give you an example
there was a study done by an online
furniture store they had furniture that
was comfortable they also had lower end
furniture that was attractive because it
was inexpensive they did an experiment
they sent half of the visitors to their
site to a background depiction of clouds
on the landing page a wallpaper of their
site so the the landing page had fluffy
clouds on the back background those
people raided comfort as the most
important factor in buying a sofa they
spent more time searching for comfort
related information inside the site and
they preferred comfortable furniture to
purchase the other half of the visitors
were sent to a site that had as its
background wallpaper pennies coins money
those people rated cost as the most
important feature for them for
purchasing a sofa they searched for
price related information and they
purchased more inexpensive furniture
they preferred to purchase more
inexpensive furniture as a consequence
so you can see that what was the central
dimension of the message it could be
comfort or it could be cost could be
installed in a customer's mind ahead of
time which caused them to see that
dimension as more important to search
for information relative to it and to
act on the basis of
product that gave them that dimension in
a prioritized way it could be cost it
could be clouds here was the interesting
thing about that study for me almost no
one recognized that they had been
influenced by the background wallpaper
it flew under the radar that means that
this is something that's not only
powerful it's also something that we
have to deal with in as as as
communicators in an ethical way because
we've got some things that are going to
move people in our direction
without them even recognizing or taking
into account that we're moving them in
their in in their direction in our
direction
[Music]